hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John one of the things that does
best on all of the YouTube is superhero
movies and lists so today we're gonna
combine it by ranking the superhero
movies of 2017 boy howdy what I would
really love for you to keep in mind is
that this is our opinion and opinions
are objective meaning these are the only
correct opinions yeah so if you disagree
with us you can comment it's just
engagement for the channel so that would
be appreciated but I'm also letting you
know you are in fact wrong and we are
the all back to school parents you might
feel that way but I'm being sincere but
it's my feelings that we judge this yeah
alright so we got eight comic book
movies to cover here number eight whoo
here we go get ready to get mad for this
beam number eight does that mean we hate
number eight no it's just number eight
guardians of the galaxy volume two oh
yeah we have reviews for all these
movies up on the channel the best word
we're gonna cover this is by just going
off of the feelings we have because
movies are an emotional experience and
those are the ones that really stick
with you and things change over the
course of a year you know like once
you've said something and been away from
it for a while the things you remember
you know and speaking of things changing
I feel like a second viewing of
guardians of the galaxy might enhance my
opinions or I might find things better
about it what I remember feeling about
it was the film was a little uneven the
comedy beats didn't quite hit for me a
lot of the time and you know there's
some stuff to appreciate I know you
really love the yondu storyline yeah my
favorite subplots this year I think
Henry Porter serial killers are cool
yeah that's really what the galaxy
needed that's a really great real like
gritty
disturbing Michael Rooker yeah but I'd
also say that our Russell was enjoyable
in it I mean there are things yeah the
issues that we have with the film I kind
of feel like that's where my feelings
have stuck who it yeah it's just not as
enjoyable as I as I hoped it would have
been and maybe there's some minor
comparison stuff to the first one that
holds back some love for the film right
now it's just number right do I like it
yeah do I love it not enough to be
number one
yeah I think back on like I enjoyed my
time watching it but at the same time it
kind of let me down I'm in the middle
about it's alright so number seven on
this list you're thinking okay which DC
EU or MCU film is it it's not either the
Lego Batman movie Hey Lego Batman movie
was a hilarious film and Will Arnett
killed it in there and the animation is
really awesome and in some ways it's one
of the better movies at its comic book
references and just honoring the comic
book world of Gotham I feel like that
really brought Gotham the life in this
movie well it's the big scale cartoon
movie it's the animated movie of the
superheroes yeah because you know we get
the the DC and the Marvel ones on the
smaller scale and this is like huge did
I love the film as much as everyone else
did I don't think I did but I can
certainly appreciate this film full
heartedly and that's why it's a big
stand out for me so intellectually I
really feel it for the Lego Batman movie
emotionally not as strong yeah I'm kind
of the same way I really enjoy I
remember enjoying movie it's not stuck
with me really it's not anything I
hadn't seen before I'm probably revisit
it at some point and have a better time
you know I feel like that one might be a
grower I'm definitely a grower haha
number six on this list is a film I
really loved and I didn't want to take
the time to argue with John over a list
like where would you I would have put
this his number can I just put her
number five sure you know okay this
number six now is King Street called
incircle
that's what's called right open secret
service room that's this second draft
yeah title before they arrived
now Kingsman the Golden Circle is better
rated and then the movie that I put at
number five but T's in the Golden Circle
that's a movie another movie this year
that I feel like I defended and John
defendant you
because I thought it was a super
enjoyable film I thought there's some
great action scenes a lot of it made me
laugh was it flawed most definitely is
it better than the first one no it's not
the film is thoroughly enjoyable there's
everything you want in a Kingsman movie
is there yes this is another episode of
the Kingsmen basically really care about
its way of you know aping James Bond and
you know poking at those tropes and
stuff and an update yeah for now that
works you know I'm not added it for
doing that yeah anything that's
repetitive or not doesn't really hit the
mark so strong I don't really care about
it I was lark I'm sure that Peter number
five on this list is a movie that was
the highest rated movie of all time on
Rotten Tomatoes it's a film that I saw
the first time and really enjoyed and I
watched it a second time and walked out
loving it one of the most debated films
of the Year Justice League woo so
Justice League is high on my list
because while I recognize the flaws that
people have with it I don't agree 100%
with all the flaws 100% if there's even
a 100 percent chance this movie could
have been longer sure there's some off
there's some CGI that's a little bit off
yeah overall I just had a great time
watching this film maybe because I'm
just a sucker for like a cool mashup and
seeing some of these characters together
for the first time especially on a
second viewing I really enjoyed the hell
out of this movie a lot I think it's
super fun I think they handle pretty
much majority of the characters really
well there's some cool action scenes and
they find make Superman cool yeah I mean
honestly I had problems with the movie
too but when I think back on it I have a
you know generally good-natured feel
like I enjoyed myself more than I did it
and there is some stuff that I thought
was really cool to see me act like it
still suffers from you know the DC sort
of blender there are some great moments
and yeah like I can see how it is still
an enjoyable cartoon you know
and I had a good time in that way I'm
not alright cartoon each one so far just
you know stuck with me a little more
like I'm building this list yeah we
talked a lot about Justice League to
like I'm not upset having a number five
just because quality wise I might have
rated it lower like the impact if we're
assembly a year endless yeah I'm with
you and I support your love of the film
well number four on this list people is
a movie that we all knew would be good
installment yeah
spider-man home come ha weirdly this is
a film this
I saw twice and the second time I
watched it I actually didn't like it as
much the first time I saw it I thought
it was a really great film and then the
second time I was like oh this is just
it's a good movie you got to give the
film a lot of credit cuz there's a lot
of moments in this movie that are very
funny a lot of great heart in it and
most importantly Tom Holland kills it
that's something that the second time I
felt even stronger about Tom Holland as
spider-man did what some might call the
impossible but I think because two other
actors have been it pretty well I
thought Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield both give different Peter
Parker's and which were really good
Peter Parker but then you get Tom
Hollands which is another different
version but it's also the closest to the
Peter Parker that I never perfect yeah
and because of that alone this is a new
redefining spider-man I feel like Andrew
Garfield looked at as the second
spider-man I say Maguire is a defining
spider-man but I would say Tom Holland
is like the redefining one and that was
a big mantle he had to take up and I
thought he killed it I'm excited to see
him in more films yeah and the movies
got a memorable villain with Sam emerald
you know plot punch and yes what are you
going Michael Keaton does a great job
and that character is pretty interesting
for once
that is funny Donald Glover is in it
yeah there's some hilarious moments in
that film number three on this list is a
movie that third time's a charm with the
Thor Ragnarok Thor Ragnarok is is a
debatable film in the film community I
noticed because people will often argue
about is there too much comedy in this
film is it too funny please I've heard a
lot of people say that about this movie
yeah and then some people will go down
to jokes that just didn't work for them
but I'm like you only name a couple of
jokes that's a comedy for you yeah like
if I walked I don't know hanging over it
was like you know there's a little too
much jokes in here cuz there were few
jokes I didn't like the gripe I
understand that people have brought up
is they feel like some of the characters
are sort of misrepresented because of
the comedy like making Loki sort of much
more of a kind of quivering Nancy in
this movie is it betrayal to some what
happens in Asgard there's kind of a
thing I'm a bunny punchline in there
that's the one complaint that I really
agreed about was how they handled Thor's
old team of how they kind of just get
killed off like they don't mean anything
I will also say I don't really care
about those guys now that I think about
it I know they were important to Thor
but I don't really remember any of their
names a film to me was a combination of
everything I would want in a movie from
the MCU
I think it's MC is best movie this year
because it is hilarious and face it guys
that's one of their signature staples is
in movies can be pretty funny and movies
hilarious the designs of the film are
incredible the CGI and the visual
effects is great
Chris Hemsworth redefining the war was
beautifully done he has a wholesome
story looks great all the other side
characters are really fantastic
there's lots there's also some great
action scenes and I can still remember
the moon
does everything that a Marvel movie
ought to do with pretty flying colors
for the most part you know and however
you feel about the comedy or not the
comedic tone I think really is in this
movie still stands out and it's arguably
the most fun I've had all year and it
uses all of its elements you know to its
advantage like it doesn't lose any of
its like it's a full-on fantasy but it
also addresses the other universe and it
also gets out into some of the cosmic
stuff yeah and it utilizes you know the
characters they made a distinct movie
with this one and they also manage to
redefine the Thor series that needed
like a terrific
domi yeah they finally got one yeah you
got him you got Cate Blanchett and Tessa
Thompson - heard like - totally bad at
female characters you know and Marvel's
gotten a lot of flack for that over the
year and it's like they're effortless in
that movie how's Chris Hemsworth is the
main reason I recommend that movie he
kills it alright so before we unveil
number two John and I both feel the same
about this is there are some days number
two would be number one yes and there
are some days number one who
participates and on this particular day
at the end of the year I have to put
this one at number two even though I
think arguably it's the better fit yeah
on your DVD shelf where it doesn't
matter yeah cuz I don't have like a
single issue with this movie I'm just
talking strictly from emotional
experience well you've had a longer love
of Wolverine in general yeah whatever
mostly well click off the video by now
so number two is located in case you
haven't picked up John I talked for
forever about this movie on on the
interweb this was a film that we saw the
on opening night and IMAX was fantastic
and we black away some black-and-white
this second time I watched it the film
is a masterpiece in my mind and I I do
think it is technically the better film
it's the most filmy film on this list
yeah and it's a great way to send off
Wolverine and even though Disney and Fox
have a deal
what I like to see you Jackman and the
Avengers sure
but I hope he doesn't do it LD is I mean
what more can you really say about this
film man it's epic in its scope and it
does something really challenging which
is for like the tenth x-men film to to
make a movie where if you watch the
other x-men movies it makes this film a
million times better
I still think one can definitely
appreciate this film without seeing the
other x-men movies it's emotional it's
got some of the best action sequences
like maybe not like crazy choreographed
or heavy visual effects but with the
intense a memorable yeah and there's
some really cool stuff in general I'm
this was a serious dour film when Logan
goes running through the forest at the
end I remember I had to chew yeah and
then I wasn't I was I think I was the
only one oh so movie like a happy cheery
it's a sci-fi western warm yeah and I'm
like that's really striking in this time
where we keep arguing about is the Bobo
go to Bruce movies like this prove that
there's so much else you can do with
these characters and whiffed you know
powers its to Oscar caliber in my
opinion yeah and Hugh Jackman I mean
he's he just lives that role and and so
does a Charles Dickens okay Patrick
Stewart yeah like perfect like that's a
terrific Professor X performance - yes
also it's their their swan songs
together
Daphne Keane yeah like they're also
completely yes oh it's a great film it's
magic and it's it's probably the best
one but I wouldn't say emotionally my
favorite one just because it's a film
you have to be patient and yeah you have
to be to watch you also remember the
second time you see it oh yeah popcorn
alright so number one is Wonder Woman
Wonder and the reason why I think Wonder
Woman is the film as a movie theater
going experience getting everything I
wanted there was energy in the room -
I've never heard like so much I think I
cried like two or three times in this
movie it's just I try a lot when I'm
alone this movie did something that I
don't think another superhero movie has
actually done for
which is move me to tears by heroism I
know right which is kind of shocking
after like the but when she walks onto
that battlefield like oh my gosh there
are times I listen to The Wonder Woman
music while I'm working it imagine the
scene of my eyes Gojira it has so much
heart I remember laughing I remember
crying I there are action sequences in
this film that are phenomenal in the
movie and some great designs it's a
period piece it's romantic sure other
issues with the finale yeah but you know
what it does that stuff pretty well
anyway and it does a whole bunch of
other interesting stuff along the way
and when it's in the finale even though
there's issues I have there's stuff in
dinner intermittently between it when
Wonder Woman is fighting Ares there's
stuff there that I don't really care
about I mean the CGI but then it would
also cut back to stuff with going on
with Stevie Trevor
and Steve Trevor you know doing his
thing maybe like start tearing up again
so you're bonded too and they're real
stakes and then it affected the fight
that she was having with Ares it had an
emotional and for patty Jenkins to like
what it would have to move to come in
and make like the defining DCE you the
remaining female super yeah take like
all the chaos from from what came before
it and turn this into like a perfectly
pretty pretty well execute to see
superhero movie that's also a period
piece like it's gets a lot of its stuff
really right and it borrows that
inspiration from Superman in a really
great way that you can pick up on but
that's not aping it at the same time and
its rousing like it's a rally this is a
beautiful film and one the comic book
movie that moved me the most this year
so do I intellectually think Logan is
the better movie mentally yeah
emotionally Wonder Woman will stole my
heart yeah well you have to agree with
our list right yeah because this is
required because you're watching while
you're watching a video and you're
hearing opinions DC paid us to tell you
to watch this video yeah DC Marvel did
too
she paid us to have guardians be number
eight and one movie number one Marvel
paid us to put Justice League number
five tomorrow Marvel said at least make
two three and four yeah and then
whatever company that did Kingsman well
Happy New Year I hope you have a great
new year full of lots and lots of joy
you know reflection and resolution I
hope you start the year off partying so
that way you can be drunken oh I'm gonna
start to do the really positive vibe
which means there's gonna be no
obstacles along the way in 2018 it's
just gonna be nothing but positivity if
I start day why not just like the whole
two years before it subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
valve you can't follow us and on the
Stardust app download to the link in
description box and check out our
patreon become a patron eject today
people it's like a second youtube
channel but a little more intimate